et avant de parler de ces accusations de
crimes de guerre abou de chat je vous
propose d'aller d'abord à kharkiv la
deuxième ville d'ukraine qui continuent
d'être bombardés on va retrouver tout de
suite notre envoyé spécial sur place
romeo langlois bonjour quelle est la
situation sur place à à kharkiv romeo
et bien kharkiv la deuxième ville
d'ukraine la situation reste extrêmement
critique vous pouvez voir juste derrière
moi la statue du célèbre poète et
ukrainiens taras chevtchenko que des
employés municipaux sont en train de
fortifier avec des sacs de sable cette
scène en dit long sur le caractère plus
qu'aléatoire des frappes de l'artillerie
russe ici à kharkiv tous les jours on
entend des explosions et tous les jours
des des
maternités des a's hôpitaux des écoles
des crèches des centres commerciaux des
stations essence sont frappés ici à
kharkiv et dans toute la région alors
les secteurs les plus touchés sont bien
sûr les secteurs nord de la ville les
plus proches de la frontière avec la
russie qui sont devenus d'immenses
quartiers fantômes ou des barres
d'immeubles entières sont sont
régulièrement détruits par l'artillerie
russe mais ces frappes peuvent survenir
à tout moment dans n'importe quel
secteur de la ville par exemple hier
dans la soirée et bien c'est une zone du
sud est qui a été touché le district de
ce lobby de ski il y aurait au moins
sept morts dont plusieurs enfants et
plus d'une quarantaine de blessés donc
la situation est extrêmement critique
les gens de car qui vivent dans un état
de stress permanent ils savent qu'à
n'importe quel moment une frappe peut
venir emporté des vies innocentes et il
semble que la situation soit encore plus
désastreuses dans les zones rurales
autour de la région de kharkiv notamment
par exemple dans la région de zoom dans
le autour de la localité de la commune
de zoom ou
le front les combats sont les plus
violents et autour de ce village ballack
l'ia qui est très proche du zoom selon
le maire de cette commune est bien 80 %
des immeubles résidentiels ont été
détruits par les frappes de arthur et
russe roméo vous avez pu vous rendre
vous dans un village dans une de ces
zones rurales autour de kharkiv vous
vous êtes rendu avec l'armée ukrainienne
qu'on est il là bas dans ce village que
vous avez plus visités
alors nous sommes rendus c'est même une
ville active c'est une ville de 40000
habitants donc une ville quand même
assez importante dans l'oblast la région
de kharkiv cette ville pendant des
semaines avait été quasiment totalement
encerclée par l'armée russe les gens
étaient totalement bloqués prises au
piège sous les bombardements mais ces
derniers jours une lors d'une contre
offensive les ukrainiens ont réussi à
repousser de plusieurs kilomètres les
russes et à reprendre notamment le
contrôle de la route principale qui
permet de relier car qui va à la ville
donc de chile/chi pente aviron 40000
habitants dans cette ville malgré tout
la situation reste extrêmement tendue
nous avons pu visiter des quartiers
entiers qui ont été totalement détruits
par les bombardements russes au moment
même où je vous parle actuellement à
kharkiv je ne sais pas si vous pouvez
entendre mais il ya une nouvelle alerte
aérienne avec une sirène qui invite tous
les gens qui sont à l'extérieur aller
vite se mettre aux abris sûrs que nous
pourrons immédiatement après ce live
donc juste pour finir de vous re à
décrire la situation autour dans la
ville de chihuahua les gens sont
extrêmement stressé une grande partie
des habitants vivent sous sol nous ont
visités donne ses sous sols où
s'entassent et environ 400 personnes
parmi lesquelles de très nombreuses
personnes âgées de très nombreux enfants
j'ai parlé avec l'un de ses enfants qui
s'appelle platon qui dit qu'il est
extrêmement stressé et même depuis sa
cache en entendez les bombardements
alors platon passe ses journées à
dessiner des tanks à dessiner des avions
de chasse et de combat et des drapeaux à
l'armée en gloire en hommage à l'armée
ukrainienne donc la situation
extrêmement difficile ces gens-là pense
que la guerre va encore continuer
pendant longtemps car vladimir poutine a
retiré ses troupes de l'ouest et
notamment de la capitale kiev et il
semble qu'il soit en train de les
déplacer vers karkhiv et vers toute la
région de l'est de l'ukraine donc les
gens ici s'attendent à une nombreux une
nouvelle et une recrudescence des
attaques russes